Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, und euch, den Hörerinnen und Hörern da draußen. Jakob, Anna, Lena, Marco, Miesel, Marco, ich vergesse einen, einen vergesse ich immer. Smonen, Smonen, Bonen, Ronen, alle sind mit dabei. Smonen, alle sind dabei, herzlich willkommen. Und am Keyboard, Thomas, vielen Dank für diesen kleinen Türöffner, dass du uns reingeschickt hast. Eher an den Drums vielleicht. An den Drums, ja, war es ein Kanon? Es hat sowas, lass uns gar nicht zu sehr auf den drei, es hat sowas Kanonisches, sowas. Frere Jacques, Frere Jacques, Frere Jacques, Frere Jacques. Nee, einer muss weitermachen. Nee, du machst, du machst nur Dormi-Vu, du machst nur Dormi-Vu, ich mach nur Frere Jacques. Das ist, glaube ich, nicht. Frere Jacques, Frere Jacques, Frere Jacques, Frere Jacques, Frere Jacques, Frere Jacques. Ich weiß auch nicht, ich hab nie verstanden, was sie singen. Ich weiß nicht, ich kann auch noch kein Französisch. Ja, das weiß ich. So, ähm, Dond, Dondest Bibliotheca, no tengo mis de beides, no tengo mis de beides. Ich kann ja bald, ich habe jetzt heute die Schule angerufen, meine ehemalige Schule, wo ich ein Abitur gemacht habe, weil ich habe dieses Jahr zehn Jahre lang mein Abitur, also zehnjähriges, es wird auch groß gefeiert in der Stufe, freue ich mich schon sehr drauf. Und man kann dann in NRW zumindest,
ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir in Bayern ist,
im Freistaat Bayern, aber im Freistaat NRW ist es so,
da kann man einfach jetzt die, hat man Einsicht.
Man hat ein Recht darauf auf seine Klausuren.
Man hat Einsicht.
Klausuren oder auch dann so Klassenbuchanmerkungen und so,
hat man so die Tapes vom Lehrerzimmer.
Du meinst das gesammelte Archiv
über die Personen, also meine Akten.
Ich will die Akten, ich will die Lehrerzimmer-Tapes,
ich will die Direktor-Tapes, ich will alle
abgehörten Telefonaten. The Confession-Tapes.
Ich will meine Eltern...
Ja, von Tietze haben wir jetzt hier.
Genau, also deine
Miranda-Rights sind
alles, was du sagst, kann und wird
gegen dich verwendet werden bei einem Elternsprechttag oder einer eingerufenen Klassensitzung. Von daher, genau, wäre super, wenn du uns alles sagst, aber wenn es dich selber belastet, kannst du schweigen und du hast das Recht auf einen Straf... Ihr könnt nach Hause gehen, ihr scheiß Lehrer, ihr könnt mir gar nichts, okay, ihr könnt mir gar nichts. Und du hast das Recht auf einen Vertrauenslehrer. Wenn du dir den nicht leisten kannst, wird dir der schlechteste gestellt. Okay? Alles klar, hast du die Miranda-Rides verstanden? Hab ich verstanden. Fahr zu, ihr Scheisselehrer, ihr könnt mich mal. Ich kann Olli ... Warte, normaler kann nicht hin. Nee, sorry, normaler kann nicht hin. Dann ist ein harter Schnitt und dann spielen sie Yu-Gi-Oh! Das war damals so, 2011. Naja, also ich freue mich drauf, man kann nicht die gesammelte Akte einlesen, leider. Ich kann nur meine drei schriftlichen Abiturprüfungen mir angucken. Boring! Lame! Diese Anekdote führt zu nichts. Das stimmt nicht. Würdest du sie denn im Podcast mitbringen, würdest du sie denn hier aktenkundig vorlegen? Kann ich machen, ich werde die Highlights gerne vorlesen. Das Ding ist ja, ein Kumpel, der hat woanders Abitur gemacht, jetzt später kennengelernt, der hat das bereits gemacht. Auch 2013 in NRW-Abitur gemacht, hat sich Gebrauch gemacht von diesem Recht und angerufen im Lehrerzimmer. Er hat mich schon vorgewarnt, dass man auf diese lustige, kleine, findige, weiß nicht, in einem Verbrauchermagazin gesehene Info, dass man sich diese Abiturprüfung jetzt einsehen kann, nicht so mega geil auf offene Ohren stösst im Lehrerzimmer. Sondern eher, und dann hat er neben dem Sekretariat angerufen, wo, und das ist dann das erste Schrecken oft, war bei mir auch so, es geht nicht die Sekretärin dran, die man kennt, die man lieb gewonnen hat, die man toll findet. Moment, es gibt eine andere Telefonnummer für Erwachsene als für Kinder? Nein. Du, wenn du das Sekretariat, wenn du das Sekretariat anrufst, dann kommst du zu einem anderen Ort? Nein, die gibt's nicht mehr, die arbeiten da nicht mehr, die arbeiten oft nicht mehr. Alle Sekretärinnen von euch allen da draußen arbeiten nicht mehr an der Schule, ist meine These. Aber die arbeiten doch schon seit 1804 da. Ja, eben. Die haben doch schon Kaiser Wilhelm, haben die doch schon irgendwie das Abitur in die Hand gedrückt und dass er seinen Sportseckel vergessen hat. Die sind doch eine Konstante in meinem Leben, das kann doch nicht sein. Genau. Und das ist der erste grosse Schrecken und dann wird man mürrisch von denen ins Lehrerzimmer weitergeleitet und da wusste ich nicht, aber hängt ein Telefon, wo der, und das ist ja nicht so, dass dann ein Lehrer Telefondienst hat, sondern der, der am nächsten an diesem Telefon gerade langläuft, der gerade eine Hand frei hat und nicht zwei Zigaretten in zwei Händen gerade hat, sondern gerade ein Gliedmasten frei hat, um noch da anzugehen. Die Frage ist nur, wie viele Kapitaten kann ein Mensch tragen und dann auch noch ein Telefon. Und dann geht jemand genervt dran und sagt, okay, gern jemand, der seine fucking Prüfungen will, Leute. Ja, hallo, ich bin Stefan Tietze, ich würde gerne nochmal nachprüfen, weil ich hatte ja damals in der Prüfung nur 13 Punkte. Oh mein Gott, das brauchen wir, mehr Podcaster. Wir haben euch nicht zu Podcastern ausgebildet. Fucking hell, Stefan, was war da, was ist mit dem los? Naja, ich... So viel Potential steckt in dir, du bist Laber-Podcaster. Ja, Sie haben recht, Herr Heinrichsen. Verdammt nochmal, reiss dich zusammen, Ernst Zern, wir haben dich immer am Zern gesehen. Ihr habt mich am Zern gesehen? Ich weiß es nicht, es ist viel Projektion in der Figur des Heinrichsen. Ich habe dich immer am Zern gesehen. Ja, es tut mir leid, ich bin nur Podcaster geworden. Ja, was ist das, was ist das? Aber ist das nicht auch ein bisschen Ihr Versagen, also sind ich es auch sehr ein bisschen verantwortlich? Weil eigentlich wollte ich anrufen, um Ihnen vorzuwerfen, dass ich nur Podcaster geworden bin. War eigentlich, glaube ich, hätte ich es ans Zern geschafft. Aber Sie haben mich krumm und krumm und bucklig gelehrt. Meine Gags waren zu stark, ich weiß. Ja. Verdammt nochmal. Das Trauma war zu tief, ich konnte es nur verarbeiten, dadurch, dass ich mit jemand anderem 375 Folgen lang rede. Genau, das war nicht das Gespräch, der Gesprächsverlauf war eher, da muss ich ja in den Keller gehen, wo die alle aufgebewahrt werden und da muss ich dann deine ganzen Klausuren finden. Und es war ein bisschen genervt, aber wahrscheinlich klappt es jetzt bald. Aber womit genau hast du gerechnet? Also er so, ah ja geil, ja klar, händigen wir die aus. Also ich meine, es ist ja wirklich, du bist der Wichtige, der von seinem Zehntausend-Schüler-Jahrgang, die drei Leute, die sich melden, bist du einer davon. Genau. Auf welche Reaktionen hat man da gehofft? Ja, eher auf eine neutrale, ah okay, machen mehrere Leute, es gibt dafür ein Protokoll. Ja. Es gibt dafür in einem Zeitpunkt jemanden, der dafür angestellt ist, vielleicht runterzugehen in diese Katakomben. Die müssen ja auch bewahrt werden. Wahrscheinlich werden sie sehr zugänglich auch bewahrt werden. Mit einem System, wo man einfach A, S, A, 2013 Abi gemacht, hier sind die Klausuren. Du willst eigentlich so einen Harry Potter-esken Hausmeister, der mit so einer Fackel und so einer Katze, die gegen jeden Geist gewappnet ist,
runter in die tropfenden Katakomben.
Genau, an den Gemälden von allen ehemaligen Schulleitern vorbei.
Ja, genau, die auch alle so einem mit den Augen folgen, einfach jedes Mal.
Und die gegenüberliegenden Leute ist leer, keine Gemälde an den Wänden,
weil die waren für die Schüler, aus denen man was wird, bestimmt.
Oh nein, aber leider niemand was geworden.
Aber niemand jemals was geworden ist. Das ist eine grosse leere Seite. Ja, aber leider, ich bin sehr gespannt, was daraus wird. Ja genau, und dann habe ich, ja, und jetzt muss da irgendwer ein armer Tropf, muss da jetzt runtergehen und dann ein Kumpel von mir hat die, wie gesagt, jetzt schon abgeholt und hat die dann abends so gelesen und er sagt, was für er dachte erst so, ah cool, man will ja eigentlich sehen, wie clever man damals war, was man gesagt hat, was man analysiert hat. Ich hatte auch Mathe-LK, keine Ahnung, ich kann mich an kein Symbol mehr erinnern. Man muss ja sagen, das war wahrscheinlich die schlauste Form von einem selbst, die es gibt. Wahrscheinlich. Du hast ja heute abgebaut. Also ich merke das ja bei dir wöchentlich. Das geht bergab. Ich merke das bei mir auch wöchentlich. Und deswegen, glaube ich, war ja der 18 Jahre alte Abitur-Stefan ja wirklich auch nochmal ganz weit oben. Pinnacle. Ja. Pinnacle of Intelligence, ja. Und dann vor allem das Takeaway war dann aber nicht von dem Freund, dass er sagt, ach so clever war ich, sondern was für ein arrogantes Arschloch war ich eigentlich, weil er hatte Englisch-LK und ich weiß nicht, ob du noch weißt, wie man halt diese Analysen beginnt, aber eigentlich mit dem Satz, in the following I may analyze. If you please, if you lend me your ear for a mere hundred lines.
A humble observer of the English art form.
My humble, honest opinion.
My humble, honest opinion on Shakespeare. I do not have any more to offer. On Willie Shakespeare. The Grave Bard! Die haben über drei Zeilen geschrieben. Mit Federn. Niemand weiss warum. Man sollte eigentlich mit dem Füller schreiben, gut leserlich, aber in so einem Kalligrafieset schreibt er in the following I may, if you please. Und da ist natürlich schon, man mag sich dann doch lieber, wie man jetzt gerade ist, wo man dieses ganze abgelegt, dieses auswendig gelernte Anfänge von diesem, das weiß ich auch noch, man hat dann so an die Hand bekommen, alle fingen ja gleich an und dann wird es irgendwann anders. Und ich habe auch mit einem Kumpel zusammen halt auch
Deutsche LK gehabt, wir haben beide die gleiche Aufgabe
auch gewählt von diesen dreien Aufgaben. Da bin ich sehr gespannt,
ob es sich überhaupt unterscheidet oder ob man einfach
so hardcore in dieses Schulsystem
getrichtert, eingetrichtert bekommt, diese
verschiedenen Punkte zu hitten,
auf die die Aufgaben schon hinaus will.
Keine Ahnung, bin ich super gespannt drauf. Also ich freue mich
da sehr drauf, aber
es ist wirklich, man ist ein arrogantes
Arschloch damals gewählt. Ich fände es wirklich interessant
und vor allem fände ich den Test interessant, ob du
Das ist ein sehrantes Arschloch damals gewesen. Ich fände es wirklich interessant und vor allem fände ich den Test interessant, ob du das heute noch schaffen würdest, die Aufgaben. Na, auf jeden Fall. Also wenn wir dich jetzt hinsetzen mit schönen Kurvendiskussionen, wie viel würdest du schaffen, im Blindtest oder auch in Deutsch, fände ich auch spannend. Also ist es was, wo du dann sagst, Alter, da wäre ich nie drauf gekommen heutzutage oder ist es dann trivial, finde ich auch nicht auch nicht schlecht. Ja, ich freue mich da jedenfalls sehr drauf. Aber wend mal, wenn du vor zehn Jahren, da müsste ich ja schon, das sind nur 30 Jahre, sag ich mal, die hätten mir holen können. Nee, das stimmt, aber ich glaube, ich weiß wie gesagt nicht, wie es in Bayern ist. Ich habe meinen Jahrgang auch nicht im Überblick, ich habe nur letztens erfahren, dass ich so, ja, da war ich letztens auf dem Jahrgangsstufen treffen und ich so, Moment, wir waren im selben Jahrgang. Nein. Und er so, ja, ja. Ich so. Spamfilter? Also, wie? Hat dir niemand aus dem Jahrgang Bescheid gesagt? Ich wurde nicht eingeladen. Du wurdest dich eingeladen? Ich wurde nicht in das Jahrgangsstufen. Du weißt warum, weil die auf den Aussagen sind, dass du eh nicht kommst. Na, das weiß ich nicht. Ich war ja schon mal bei einem Jahrgangsstreffen. Und da hast du dich aufgeführt wie, hast du im ersten Mal Alko getrunken und warst ein Riesenarschler. Ja, das tut mir leid. Aber ich habe tatsächlich, glaube ich, das Erbärmlichste gemacht, was man machen kann.
Und zwar war ich beim Jahrgangsstufentreffen des Jahrgangs unter mir.
Ich war in einem Jahrgangsstufentreffen, in dessen Jahrgang ich nicht war.
Und war dann natürlich so einer der Fremdesten, die es jemals gehört habe, die es überhaupt geben kann. Ich war dann wirklich einfach so offensichtlich, du bist nicht Teil der Gruppe.
Das ist ein sehr gutste, was ich jemals gehört habe. die es überhaupt geben kann. Ich war halt dann wirklich einfach so offensichtlich, du bist nicht Teil der Gruppe. Das ist so, wie wenn du so ein Haha, das grosse Treffen der Rothaarigen oder sowas, und du bist da halt einfach nicht, einfach passt da nicht rein, einfach so, ja, ich bin dabei. Aber auch spannend, wie das kippt, also wie man, wenn man zur Schule geht, die Älteren, auch speziell der Jahrgang drüber, immer die Könige und Königinnen sind, immer Wahnsinn, wie sind die erwachsen, wie gut sehen die aus, wie krass sind die eigentlich. Die haben ein Auto. Die haben ein fucking Auto. So, und jetzt dann, wenn du halt zehn Jahre später zu dem Jahrgangstreffen von Leuten unter dir gehst, da ist aber das Alter eher ein Problem wahrscheinlich. Da sagen die, was für ein Weirdo. Absolut, es war auch ein Riesenfehler, weil Facebook hat mir einfach angezeigt, Jahrgangsstufen treffen und ich hatte nicht nachgedacht, welches. Ich dachte einfach, ja, das wird meins sein, weil ich meine, Mark Zuckerberg würde mich doch nicht komplett hintergehen. Ich meine, der war auf Harvard. Er hat mich komplett geprankt. Fucking Harvard. Ich habe Social Network gesehen. Der war nicht, der ist nicht über alle Zweifel erhaben. Der ist vielleicht nicht der Netteste, aber er ist clever. Ja, der ist schlau. Der wird mir jetzt nicht das falsche Jahres haben. Nee, absolut nicht. Deswegen bin ich da einfach blind hingegangen. Und dann Mark Zuckerberg! Und dann war ich da. Und dann wollte ich auch nicht sofort wieder gehen, weil das so ein, ja, der zeigt sich mal und ist dann weg. Das war war so eine ganz komische Sackgassensituation, wo es kein wirklich gutes Protokoll gab.
Und dann hing ich da noch so ein bisschen rum, aber hab auch
relativ lange gebraucht, bis ich es gemerkt hab.
Weil man denkt sich ja so, ah ja krass, der den
hab ich nie so wirklich gesehen. Ach krass, mit dem hatte ich gar nicht so
viel zu tun. Und irgendwann denkt man sich,
ich kenne ja niemanden
wirklich so. Ach scheiße.
Das ist ja ganz furchtbar.
Das Gute ist, dass man bei dir noch denken kann, dass sie so einen Special Guest eingeladen haben von der Schule. Weiss ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Aber jetzt war ich im Jahrgangsstufentreffen nicht dabei und ja, schade, anscheinend war es richtig cool, wir haben alle nochmal alle so über alles geredet, die frühe Zeit damals, ja, aber da haben die irgendwie wieder so den Wagen vom Vater und dann wollten die nach der Abifahrt noch so zum McDonalds fahren und ich stand so am Parkplatz und dachte mir, krass, dann machen die und dann haben die so, weil die waren schon angetrunken und so und dann haben die den, das war so geil, weil die sind dann ins Auto gegangen und dann sind die so ähm dann wollten die so losfahren und dann waren die aber schon ein bisschen angetrunken. Und dann sind die da reingefahren und dann sind die dann so einen Schneehaufen reingefahren direkt. Und ich so, Vorsicht Leute! Die waren ein gutes Stück weg. Und die saßen im Auto und hatten auch Musik an und so. In den Schneehaufen rein. Das war so geil. Und dann standen die im Schneehaufen und dann haben die wahrscheinlich vielleicht gesagt so, boah, fuck. Aber du warst zu weit weg. Ich war recht tief weit weg, ich konnte nicht immer die Lippen lesen, aber dann meinten die so, boah, jetzt sind wir da im Schnee, sollen wir noch weiterfahren? Ich weiss es nicht genau, wie gesagt. Aber das war schon krass. Da hätten wir noch so ein bisschen drüber reden können. Du stand, du warst da, du standst nur auf der anderen Straßenseite den ganzen Abend?
Ich war auf der anderen Seite des Seberstreifens, wir waren auf dem Parkplatz und also ich hab, ich bin dann so, ich bin erst aus der Tür gegangen, als sie im Schneehaufen waren, aber man könnte auch anderen, also das ist vielleicht nicht deine Geschichte, die zu erzählen. Naja, das war so krass wie wir damals, also wie ich zugeschaut habe, wie ihr. Also wir hatten halt so ein bisschen Erinnerungen. Ja, du erzählst Geschichten. Ja, aber dann kommen ja noch so andere Erinnerungen hoch, irgendwie so. Ja. Wo die dann, wo dann irgendwie so Abi-Streich und so, und dann haben die halt wirklich Und du? Also du warst dabei. Die sind ja auf dem obersten Schockgang und dann haben die die Stühle alle aufs Dach und so. Und das war so witzig, weil ich so, Leute, Achtung, falls ihr seid, ich war ganz unten, ganz unten, im untersten Stockwerk. Und da habe ich gesagt, boah, wenn ich die runterschmeiße. Aber du weißt ja, die Stühle ist ja so hoch, die können wir ja nicht gehört haben. Na, weiß ich. Und du hast nicht immer mit denen interagiert. Ja, ich kannte die halt ganz gut, vier oder fünfter Stock. Hey, du kannst nicht immer Geschichten erzählen, wo du nicht der Partner bist. Was ich, äh, warte, warte, warte, erinnerst du dich noch, was ich gesagt habe? Nein, ich habe gesagt, hey Leute, schmeiß die Stühle nicht runter, sonst, äh, was habe ich gesagt? Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich gesagt habe, es war sauwitzig. Nee, du warst nicht Teil davon. Es war sauwitzig. Ich meine sogar, du warst krank an dem Tag, also vielleicht hast du. Ja, ich habe da vorhin eine Schülerzeitung gelesen, aber es war saulustig. Also ich denke mir halt so, ich hätte wahrscheinlich gesagt, boah, pass mit den Stühlen auf. Weil wir mögen dich ja alle echt gerne. Du sollst dringend aufhören zu rauchen. Du musst nicht rauchen, wenn du nicht willst. Nee, Mann, geil. Ich weiß noch, wo ihr dann an der Raucherecke standet. Und dann weiß ich noch, dann war ich im Klassenzimmer und dann so, wo ist denn der Ramon und die Elisabeth? Und ich so, boah, scheiße, die sind am Rauchereck. Und dann habe ich gesagt, die sind noch,, ja das war die Parallelklasse, aber die, ich habe die dann noch gesehen, weil ich musste da kurz raus und wollte den Overhead-Projekt holen und dann sind wir entgegen und die halt so voll, boah ey, wir kommen zu spät, wir kommen zu spät und ich so, boah alter, die kommen bestimmt zu spät und so, das war echt eine coole Zeit. Hör mal zu, hör mal kurz zu, weil wir mögen dich alle echt gerne, aber du erzählst Geschichten, wo du nicht Teil davon bist. Du bist nicht der Protagonist. Ich hab's genau gesehen, es war so krass. Warum machst du das? Weil du willst dazugehören, aber das macht dich irgendwie noch uncooler. Ey, geiles Team damals, ihr macht du warst nicht dabei, es ist nicht so schlimm es tut mir leid, ich hab's beobachtet ja, wir fanden es ein bisschen creepy auch mit so einem Trenchcoat, so einem klischeehaften Trenchcoat, auch mit einem Feldstecher standst du immer auf der anderen Seite ich war so peinlich, aber es war creepy, peinlich gar nicht mehr und nach dem Gerichtsprozess hast du ja eigentlich auch gesagt bekommen, du sollst mehr Abstand halten. Und aufhören zu rauchen. Das war auch noch so ein Ding. Ja, das war krass. Ey, aber cool, dass wir nochmal zusammenkommen und so. Das war echt krass. Das war echt krass, also weiß ich noch. Ich habe mir jetzt nochmal die Klausur angeguckt, wo ich ja 13 Punkte gekommen habe und ihr meintet so, boah, 13 Punkte, ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, was ihr gesagt habt, aber ich meine so, boah, 13 Punkte, ich habe es kaum gelernt. Das ist nicht dein Jahrgang. Ihr habt gar nicht. Das ist nicht dein Jahrgang. Ach so. Wir waren der Jahrgang drei Stufen unter dir. Ach so, oh, oh ja, okay. Ich dachte mir schon. Wir haben aber gehört, wir wurden vorgewarnt, also vorher vom Organisationskomitee, dass du bei jedem dabei bist. Ja, ich bin bei jedem Klassen. Ich bin immer dabei. Ich mag es einfach ein bisschen so in Erinnerung zu sprechen. Aber irgendwann wird es zu schwierig, irgendwann bist du zu alt. Irgendwann ist es wirklich mega merkwürdig, wenn du irgendwie bei, wenn Leute irgendwie 15 Jahre jünger sind. Krass, dass selbst ihr irgendwie Geschichten von mir kennt, schon legendär gewesen sein, dass ihr dann irgendwie die Sachen kennt. Ja, der Stadt Creep. Du bist der Stadt Creep. Ja. Also, es tut mir leid, alles, was mit dir passiert ist, tut mir sehr leid. Ich war oft allein auch. Okay.
Ich war dann manchmal noch im Biosaal, als dann die Schule schon vorbei war.
Geht da nicht die Alarmanlage oder so an?
Da ist einmal die Alarmanlage angegangen.
Das siehst du, das ist eine Geschichte.
Warum erzählst du die nicht?
Das ist mega, das ist auch, also, ne, Baby Steps, aber es ist cooler.
Es ist auch creepy ein bisschen, aber es ist cooler als zu Geschichten zu erzählen, wo du nicht dabei warst.
Okay, cool.
Und dann ist die Alarmanlage angegangen?
Ja, die Alarmanlage ist angegangen.
Hey Leute, kommen wir dazu, Jerry erzählt eine Geschichte, wie die Alarmanlage in der Schule gegangen ist.
Ja, weil, also, da war ich dann noch im Biosaal, nachdem schon Schule aus war, und, ähm, haben auch? Klar, ja, natürlich. Mega. Und dann kommt so ein sehr lindig-jungartiger Weihnachtssong. Das könnte so ein Weihnachtssfilm sein. Ja. Es schneit draußen, Leute haben feiern und dann ist dieser Creep eingeladen. Und findet er auch zu sich. Und plötzlich finden sie zu ihm, weil er plötzlich merkt, es gibt gute Geschichten. Reisen in der Zeit zurück. Und dann können sie es nochmal neu machen. Ist eine Idee, ist ein angstfreier Raum, also wir können Ideen äußern, es ist gar kein Problem, also wie gesagt, ich schreibe es auch gerne auf. Und dann irgendwas schief, dann steckt er in der Alarmanlage fest und dann immer so Hallo Leute, ich will ihr in der Alarmanlage reinstecken. Warum macht die Alarmanlage so? Dann wird immer so Du, Du, Du. Und warum kann er nur sprechen? Ich bin in der Alarmanlage gefangen, ich verrenne mich raus und die so schnell raus und so. Weil er ist dann in der, er ist die Alarmanlage und die anderen müssen dann gucken, ob sie noch dasarmanlage besauen. Okay, alles klar. Und dann gibt es diese Diskussion, ey Leute, Jerry ist in der Alarmanlage festgesetzt worden. Jerry ist in der Alarmanlage festgefangen. Hey, wir müssen irgendwas dagegen tun. Hat jemand eine Idee, was wir machen können? Was können wir machen? Wir können die Achtklässler fragen, die wissen schon mehr als wir. Okay. Ja, wissen auch nicht, was sie machen. Keine Ahnung, Leute, ey. Wir haben Auto. Und Zigaretten. Zerretten. Zerretten, ey. Auto und Zigaretten. Manchmal nehmen wir eine Zigarette und dann machen wir die am Auspuff vom Auto an. Dann gehen wir zum Auspuff und dann machen wir die alle die Zigarette an, Mann. Okay? Okay. Weil du so einen Flammenauspuff hast an dem Ford-Kar. Ja, Mann, das ist richtig cool. Das ist ein Ford- Ford Car. Hey, das ist richtig cool. Ich sag, das ist der einzige Weg, die Zigarette anzumachen. Ist der Auspuff deines Ford Cars. Ja klar Mann, alles ist der Ford Car meiner Mutter. Ford Car, brillanter Titel. Titel eines Autos. Ford Car, Ford Auto. Brillant, finde ich stark. Car. War tatsächlich eine Zeit lang ein Auto, wo ich ein Auge drauf geworfen habe als Elfjähriger. Meine Mom hatte einen langen Ford Car. Habe ich geliebt. Ja? Hast du ein Auge drauf geworfen als Elfjähriger? Ich dachte mir, eines Tages fahre ich mit so einem Ding zum Lidl und stelle mich auf den Parkplatz und steige aus. Fros, komm da, setz dich mal zu kurz zu Papa, komm mal her, komm mal auf den Schoss, hallo. Hallo, hallo, Heinrich. Du hast so realistische Ziele, dass ich mir ein bisschen Sorgen mache. Papa, wenn ich groß bin, dann will ich mal in der Steuerkanzlei arbeiten, als Steuerfachangestellter. Und dann von dem Gehalt, naja, nach Steuer, würde ich mir dann einen Ford K holen und dann eines Tages würde ich mal zum Lidl fahren und dann würde ich mir da die frischen Paprikas holen. Genau, und dein Lieblingsauto war was nochmal? Ein Mustang, ein cooler Mustang oder ein Porsche 911? Ne, ein gebrauchter Ford Car reicht ja völlig.
Ein gebrauchter Ford Car reicht ja völlig.
Ja, reicht ja völlig.
Aber du kannst doch nach den Sternen, greift doch nach den Sternen.
Warum willst du kein Rockstar werden oder zumindest Astronaut oder so?
Nee, ich würde lieber einen gebrauchten Ford Car fahren und alleine brauche ich ja nicht viel.
Alleine?
Wenn ich ja dann einmal in der Woche würde ich einkaufen fahren, kriege ich eigentlich alles im Kofferraum.
Du bist ja alleine, du hast doch wahrscheinlich eine Familie mit fahren, kriege ich eigentlich alles im Kofferraum.
Du hast doch wahrscheinlich eine Familie mit fünf, zehn Kindern.
Ich bin Junggeselle.
Ja, ich bin Junggeselle.
Aber manchmal freitags, da hole ich mir dann so Würstchen und mache Hotdogs mit dieser Tube, wo gleichzeitig Senf und Ketchup drin ist.
Weil dann denke ich mir, dann brauche ich nur eine Tube und dann habe ich nicht das Problem, dass Ketchup und Senf gleich, dann, Papa, wo tust du mich hin?
Naja, das war ja auf dem Teppich, dachte ich. Für so ein Kind ist das ein langer Fall. Aber das denke ich mir häufig, das denke ich mir häufig, wenn ich höre, Insekten.
Man sagt ja bei Insekten häufig, die können das hunderttausendfache ihres Körpergewichts tragen. Und dann soll man für die applaudieren und aufstehen und sagen, wow, das ist krass, du verdienst jede Medaille dieser Welt. Ich denke mir, wenn die runterfallen zum Beispiel,
würde ich, also das ist ja gemessen an deren
Körpergrösse
ein riesiger Fall, so wie ich vom
Empire State Building springe.
Überlebe ich nicht.
Die doch.
Weil die, aber so klein sind,
nichts wiegen. Ja, das stimmt.
Heißt für mich, Gewichte
im Kleinen sind nicht
aussagekräftig. Gewichte im Kleinen
Vielen Dank. aber so klein sind nichts wiegen. Ja, das stimmt. Heißt für mich, Gewichte im Kleinen sind nicht aussagekräftig. Gewichte im Kleinen, wir haben eine, die Gravitation ist für uns alle gleich, die kämpfen mit unlauteren Mitteln. Die kämpfen mit, die Gravitation, okay, wenn du Gravitation die Tietze-Konstante nennen willst, dann bin ich dich daran zu hindern. Ich dachte, die Tietze-Konstante, wenn Dinge klein sind, dann zählen sie nicht so richtig. Das ist die Tietze-Konstante. Die Tietze, ja genau. Die Tietze-Abfälligkeit. Dafür gilt es nicht. Das ist was anderes. Nee, aber so, ich finde es einfach mega uncool, dass man denen so viel Credit gibt, weil, ne, also wie gesagt, für mich, ich bin, ich wiege, weiß nicht, 85 Kilo. Wenn ich vom Empire State Building springe, sterbe ich. Wenn ich so einen riesengrossen Knödel, wenn man das hochrechnet, von so einem Misskäfer den Knödel auf mich, das wäre viel mehr und das wäre so schwer. Könntest du nicht heben. Könnte ich nicht heben, aber es liegt nicht an meiner Unfähigkeit, sondern weil grosse Massen, finde ich, anders bewertet werden müssten. Das meine ich ja die Tietze-Konstante so. Kleine Massen müssen anders gedacht werden. Tietze-Eyebrow. Ist das klein genug? Tietze-Skepsis. Ist das klein genug? Ja. Aber gilt es für schwerere Dinge auch? Also schaut ein Elefant ein Mensch an und denkt sich, oh, Mensch, so langsam will ich auch gern runterfallen. Wenn ich runterfallen, dann geht es ganz schnell. Sowas, oder? Also wie wir einen Käfer anschauen, sagt der Elefant, meinst du hier Menschen, diese Menschen haben immer diesen Schlosschen. Ich finde das klasse, dass du neuerdings so prägnant und toll und gut beobachtet in Dinge hineinversetzt.
Letzte Woche hatten wir es mit Volvo, das ganz tolle Volvo-Impersonation oder von anderen Automarken.
Jetzt bist du ein Tier. Jetzt frage ich mich, wie klingt zum Beispiel ein Gepard?
Hey, Leute, wir müssen unbedingt ganz schnell...
Äh, nee, bin ich der Schnelle? Nee, Leute, lass, komm doch mal rein.
Geh, Part.
Der Schnellste?
Mhm.
Nee, war gut, also, wäre jetzt auch neu, wenn es... Hey, Leute, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, Hey, Leute! Hey, seid ihr auch schon fit für eine neue Runde? Hey, immer in Bewegung bleiben, wer nicht läuft, rostet ein! Ja, Tapie habe ich auch schon so der Radiomoderator, der so Lokalradios ab 22 Uhr übernimmt. Weißt du, eine Heimatstadt, die Leute, die ab 22 Uhr anfangen zu moderieren. Das ist so typisch Tapie.
Genau, das ist so typisch Tapie. Hey, jetzt nochmal die Altesnitz aus der Steinzeit. Und jetzt kommt Stein auf Stein, das gönne ich mir. Viel Spaß. Kannst sehr toll Steine imitieren.
Dankeschön.
Es gibt gerade so ein Meme, ähm, vielleicht. Du kannst sehr toll Steine imitieren.
Es gibt gerade so ein Meme, das fand ich sehr lustig, eine gute Beobachtung, dass man nie die gleiche Mikrowelle bei Leuten zu Hause sieht. Okay, jeder hat eine andere Mikrowelle. Okay, ja. Ich finde das so eine lustige Beobachtung. Hochindividuell. Ja. Das sind alles Unikate. Weil es kann gar nicht so viele geben.
Aber ich habe noch nie die Mikrowelle, die ich zu Hause damals hatte, beim Elternhaus noch, und die, die ich nachmach hatte, ich habe jetzt gar keine mehr, aber man sieht überall andere, aber es kann nicht so viele Modelle geben. Es gibt fünf Marken oder so, gängig, die man da kauft, aber ich habe noch nie eine, zwei Mal gesehen. Ich hatte nie eine Mikrowelle bei uns im Kinderhaus, ich glaube, was man als Kind nicht hat, kauft man dann auch nicht. So, wenn du nie eine Mikrowelle hattest, habe ich jetzt nie das Bedürfnis, gar eine Mikrowelle zu kaufen. Ich hatte nie eine Mikrowelle, aber meine Mutter hat denen einfach nicht getraut, hat gesagt, Moment mal. Unsichtbar? Bin ich mir nicht sicher. Ich dachte immer so, ja, was ist denn ein Ofen? Anders als der Backofen. Ich meine, da wird halt alles heiß und bei der Mikrowelle halt nur das Essen. Ja, aber das ist diese magische Zutat. Ja, ja, was ist denn ein Ofen? Anders als der Backofen, ja. Ich meine, da wird halt alles heiß und bei der Mikrowelle halt nur das Essen, aber... Ja, aber das ist diese magische Zutat. Ja, ja, das stimmt schon. Sodass man dann sagt, weiss ich nicht. Am Ende werde ich gekocht und das Essen ist kalt. Es ist schlecht pitchable, so eine Mikrowelle. Ja, ja. So, okay, innen drin wird es nicht heiß. Ah, okay, das heißt, ich kann meine Hand reinhalten. Nein, nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Oh, ja, auf gar keinen Fall. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Sie dürfen auf gar keinen Fall Ihre Hand reinhalten. Aber eine Schüssel? Nein, nein, nein, nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Nein, nein, nein, sind Sie wahnsinnig? Nein, nein, nein, Sie dürfen nur Essen reintun. Ja, genau, so ein Milchreis. Dann machen Sie die Klappe zu. Dann machen Sie die Klappe zu. Milchreis in einer Schüssel. Nein, auf gar keinen Fall, auf gar keinen Fall. Auf gar keinen Fall eine Schüssel. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Sie müssen den Milchreis lose in die Mikrowelle reintun. Naja, aber was mich mal verwirrt ist, ist... Ich späte auf, dass ich keine Mikrowelle habe. Ja, wollte ich gerade sagen. Das ist wirklich nicht die beste Besetzung für diese Rolle. Sternchen für den Sketch. Man kann Schüsseln einfach reinstellen. Okay. Und sorry, ich wollte jetzt ihren Film nicht kaputt machen, aber man hat mir gesagt, dass sie extra mich für die Rolle wollten und deswegen dachte ich, weil ich einfach mit einem frischen Blick vielleicht rangehen kann, weil ich es einfach nicht kenne. Einfach ein Skript halten trotzdem. Es gibt ein Skript? Es gibt ein Skript? Wow, Sie sehen, jeder Schauspieler am Set. Wow! Oh, oh, snap! Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, Oh, snap! Nee, aber was ich nicht verstanden habe, dann diese so harte Materialien, das war meine Kindheitserklärung dafür, harte, inorganische Materialien, wie zum Beispiel Keramik oder so, der Schüssel, Milchreis da drin, es wird sauheiss, sauheiss, Schüssel wird nicht heiß, Schüssel ist drin, wird nicht heiß. Ach so, je weicher, desto heisser. Das war meine Kinderstheorie, je weicher ein Material ist, slash flüssig, desto heisser wird es. Harte Materialien wie Stein oder Keramik werden nicht heiß. Ausser dann, und Achtung, das darf man nicht vergessen, das ist ein grosser Punkt, wenn der Milchreich sehr heiß wird, wird die Schüssel ausschnell sehr heiß. Okay. Aber sonst nicht. Aber könnte man technisch gesehen die Mikrowelle nicht als Waffe benutzen? Ich denke jetzt gerade in Actionfilmen. Actionfilm, wir haben jetzt schon Kill Bill, die Cornflakes-Packung, unübliche Dinge werden als Waffe benutzt. Und jetzt, ja, irgendwie Kind, Kevin allein zu Hause, wird bedrängt von Schlägern, die schlagen auf ihn ein und er was mache ich, hüpft auf den, ähm, grössten? Ne, ne, ne, wie heisst das? Empire State Building. Nein, die Ablage. Frankreich. Nein, die Ablage. Flamingos. Nein, nein, nein, die Ablage, die in der Küche, die Ablage. Neunzehn. Wurzel zwei. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, aber na, wir sind, die Ablage. Wie heißt der Autor von? Kitchen Counter, die Tappel, Tappablage. Anrichte. Die Anrichte, so. Genau, das war's.
Springt drauf, packt sich die Mikrowelle,
ist schlau, weil jeder weiß, wenn die
Mikrowelle offen ist, geht's nicht an.
Also klemmt er diesen
Hahn zu, damit das Gerät denkt,
das ist zu. Und dann macht er die Mikrowelle
an, richtet sie auf die Schläger,
die im Begriff sind, ihn zu schlagen, und
währenddessen schmelzen ihre Fäuste.
Hm. Filmende. Microwaves, microwaving, waving. Macrowaves, Corley Culkin. Ich würde gerne das mal als Waffe sehen, aber es macht keinen Sinn, dass es noch nicht im Krieg eingesetzt wurde. Kann man da nicht was geschmelzen? Ich glaube, man hat mal versucht, ich glaube, die Idee war, die Wasservorräte der Gegner zu evaporieren, mit riesigen Mikrowellen, weil die machen ja irgendwie das Wasser. Eine kleine Einmerkung. Ja, der Film geht gleich los, aber wir können gerne, ja bitte. Warum nicht die Menschen evaporieren, evaporisieren? Ja, die Menschen können sich bewegen, die merken, boah, heiß, oder? Meine Haut kocht. Gehe ich ein Stück zur Seite. Das haben wir an Tschernobyl gesehen. Was haben wir an Tschernobyl gesehen? Ich habe Tschernobyl nicht gesehen, sorry. Ah, okay. Nee, ich wollte nur sagen, die würden ja nicht wegrennen. Ich glaube schon, dass sie wegrennen würden, wenn sie merken würden, dass es ihnen plötzlich sehr heiß wird. Aber da haben wir anscheinend andere Meinung. Sonst noch Fragen? Vorm Film ist ja unüblich auch, Fragen zuzulassen. Ich bin auch nur Kino-Mitarbeiter. Ich habe jetzt den Film nicht gemacht. Okay, nee, dann roll das Ding ab. Alles klar, ich roll das Ding ab. Ernste Frage, also warum nicht Mikrowellen auf Feinde? Erstmal ethische Probleme. Menschen sind keine Hotpockets. Zweites Problem, der Mensch kann einfach weglaufen.
Das ist ein ganz kategorischer Imperativ, ne?
Menschen sind keine Hot Pockets.
Drittes Problem, der Mensch kann natürlich einfach einen Helm aufsetzen.
Wasser nicht, es gibt keine Helme für Wasser.
Du kannst nicht einen wassergrossen Helm jetzt über ein ganzes Wasser basen.
Da hast du keine Chance.
Das Basen, da kannst du das Basen mal schön vergessen, da sei es schon gleich. Da ist das Basen aber Geschichte. So, und dann richten diese auf Basen und dann ist das Wasser alles weg. Aber was machst du mit der Wolke, ist die Frage. Du brauchst ja dann noch leistungsstarke Dieselmotoren, die diese Wolke direkt in die eigene Richtung wehen, damit es schön bei dir, bei deinen eigenen Truppen abregeln, nicht beim Gegner wieder selbst, sonst hast du ein Problem. Dass wir generell nicht mehr am Wetter verändern, verstehe ich bis heute nicht. Das war immer so eine Verschwörungstheorie, als ich noch kleiner war, dass das Wetter regelmäßig verändert wird. Ist auch, glaube ich, so ein bisschen in dieser Camp-Trail-Geschichte mit drin. Ja, das macht man schon auch. Ich habe das ja mal recherchiert und es gibt es auch tatsächlich, dass das ab und zu gemacht wurde, so zu grossen Militärparaden von grossen Regimen, dass man da einfach die Wolken weggeschossen hat. Ich denke eher an die EM nächstes Jahr. Möglich, recht das meine, aber die Technologie ist da, man kann auf jeden Fall die Wolken wegballern einfach. Die schießen dann auf die Wolken drauf und dann weinen die Wolken und dann weinen die alles weg. Dieses Jahr ist ja kein schönen Sommer. Deswegen meine ich so, warum nicht einfach mal, oder kann ich es auch im Kleinen machen? Weil mein Geburtstag ist ein bisschen ins Wasser gefallen. Ich glaube, was du machen kannst, ist Wolken, die Wolke sagt so, in drei Tagen lasse ich hier alles vom Stapel. Und dann ballerst du so lange auf die Wolke ein, bis sie sagt, ja, heute schon. Heute schon, genau. Heute schon, damit die... Einfach wie so eine Spritze rein... Das ist wie Ballast, das ist wie Ballast. Die wirft dann Ballast ab, damit die Wolke wegkommt. Ja, genau. Die wirft ihre Kinder weg, damit sie schneller laufen kann. Aber das ist doch voll möglich. Warum wird es nicht die ganze Zeit gemacht? Ich denke auch an die Landwirtschaft. Ich denke an Weine. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, ständig auf Wolken zu schießen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist generell. Oder ob das so effektiv ist. Soweit ich weiß, ich habe das immer recherchiert wegen Verschwörung Chemtrails und so. Genau. Und ein großes Argument der Verschwörungstheoretiker ist immer... Du meinst, dass du selber Verschwörungstheoretiker warst. Genau, ein großes Argument ist, ja, da gibt es ja Patente und da gibt es ja Technologie und so und das gibt es ja auch, aber man hat sich dann letzten Endes gedacht, nee, lass uns lieber CO2 verringern, anstatt einfach irgendwas in die Luft zu sprühen, was dann die Sonnenanstrahlung reflektiert und, war es ein Fehler? Ja. Reicht? Aber deswegen. Keine Ahnung, ich kenne mich nicht gut aus.
Es gibt doch noch diese radikalen, es gibt doch, kann mir keiner erzählen, klar, Klimaziele, okay, bin ich alles dabei, aber wenn das alles nicht klappt, ich weiß, ich habe selber sehr Angst vor dieser Route, wenn ich gerade einschlage. Du glaubst, es gibt einen Notknopf, oder was? Nee, ich glaube, es gibt so eine radikalische, eine alberne Lösung.
Es wird im Endeffekt eine alberne Lösung, aber so eine Notlösung wie zum Beispiel so einen Riesensonnenschirm. Ja, genau. Wir spannen einen grossen Sonnenschirm auf. Oder so eine Snapback. So eine Yankee-Snapback. Die Erde kriegt so eine grosse, oder unschön diese Anglerhüte. Ja genau, ja ja.
Aber irgendwas in groß, jetzt niemand will diese Lösung, unsexy Lösung, aber man kennt das ja auch von sich so, Stichwort dann Matheklausur oder sowas, man vertraut Lösungen ja auch nicht, die nicht schön sind, sondern man hat ja immer so als Mensch die Erwartung, weil das, weiß nicht, es gibt eine gewisse Abstraktion im Menschen. So, die Lösung, die man erwartet, muss dann auch schön sein, muss passen, wie enttäuscht man dann immer ist, wenn manche Lösungen vielleicht nicht optimal so in die krasseste Vorstellung, die man hatte, passen. Und deswegen glaube ich, wir denken vielleicht nicht kreativ genug. Du hast mal gesagt, alles Weiss anmalen. Alles Weiss anmalen? Nee? Aber ich hatte letztens auch eine gute Idee. Und zwar dachte ich mir, die Sache ist ja die, es gibt ja manchmal so tolle Entdeckungen von einem Laien. Amateurentdeckungen. Ja, meine Idee, ich hätte eine Amateurentdeckung. Ich habe auch eine Amateurentdeckung. Meine Amateurentdeckung wäre nämlich folgende Idee. Man hat sowas wie eine Wasserrose, Seerose. Ja, Lotus. Lotus Seerose. Du hast recht. Auf dem Wasser. Gr Ja. Größer, größer, größer, größer, größer. Boah, bin ich gross. Und jetzt kommt der entscheidende Punkt, die geht unter. Die ist ab dem gewissen Punkt so gross, dass sie untergeht, Meeresboden, und dann ist es weg. Weil dann ist ja CO2 gespeichert und weg. Problem ist ja, wenn du die Seerose hast, dann ist ja CO2 erstmal weg und die Welt atmet auf. Puh! Aber dann geht die Seerose kaputt und dann geht das alles wieder heraus. Und deswegen sage ich unter Wasser. So, und jetzt ist meine Frage an die Experten, ist die Idee gut genug, dass ich da mal anrufe? Moment, aber CO2 ist ja trotzdem noch. Dass ich da mal anrufe. Ja, aber das ist ja weggesunken im Meer. CO2 ist doch auch ein Gas, wird doch auch oben. Nee, das bleibt dann unten. Die Idee ist nur, dass es runtersinkt, quasi. Ja, meine Idee ist, mir ist peinlich. Wir pickeln alle ins Meer. Mir ist aufgefallen, wenn man Hu macht, also so, pass auf, wenn du, pass auf, nee, aber jetzt hör mal auf, hör mal alle auf zu lachen kurz. Mach mal, also wenn du wie pustest, fühl mal wie kalt das ist, kalt. Problem ist, das wäre gut, Problem ist, das wäre auch, aber mach mal, wie wärmer das ist, viel wärmer. Also, mehr Hu als Haar, Mehr Hu als Haars. Nur weil, ich weiß, wenn wir, aber, das ist erstmal einalbern, aber ihr habt vorher gesagt, dass es ein angstfreier Raum ist. Das ist nicht, warum alle jetzt nicht auslachen. Und klar, es ist im Kleinen, ist ein kleines Ding, kleiner Beitrag, aber wenn wir alle mehr Hu statt Haarsas machen. Ist stimmt, wenn man versucht, was zu beschlagen. Zwei Grad. Durch die Brille zum Beispiel, dann macht man. Aber wenn man was kalt pusten will, wie ein Tee. Es geht um das klassische Pusten. Aber was ist jetzt eine Idee, dass man jeden Tag eine Stunde lang und damit die Erde abkühlt? Erstmal reicht es mir ja nur. Aber willst du Haars reduzieren oder Hues erhöhen? Das ist ja auch ein systemisches Problem und liegt nicht so sehr am Individuum selber. Ich glaube nur, wenn jeder sich an die eigene Nase fasst und immer wenn man ein Haar machen würde, eher ein Hues macht, dann ist es glaube ich, dann haben wir schon mal ein paar Grad vielleicht rausgeholt. Aber was ist dir wichtiger, Haars zu reduzieren oder Hues zu erhöhen? Immer erstmal alles zu ersetzen. Jedes Haar kann durch ein Hues ersetzt werden. Wirklich? Naja, wenn du deine Brille beschlagen willst, kannst du nicht dagegen blasen. Da denkst du mal, du bist der Vollidiot der Welt. Reduziert. Reduziert die Haars. Wie? Weniger Haars. Das fängt ja schon an. Warum muss die Brille sauber gemacht werden? Was gibt es überhaupt zu sehen? Wo glotzt du eigentlich hin? Was ist vorher passiert? Offensichtlich von Bullshit, dass du deine Brille sauber machen musst. Okay, also halte die Brille sauber, damit ihr Haas einspart. Genau. Okay. Ja, wir melden uns, wir nehmen das mal. Ich will damit den Nobelpreis. Ich stelle mir vor, dass jetzt irgend so ein Klimaforscher zuhört und so.
Und dann nimmt dann so eine Riesenformel hinter ihm, so eine Riesenformel.
Und er dreht sich einfach nur um und ergänzt meinen Hus und Haas.
Genau.
Und dann, Susanna, ruf Nobel an.
Oh, Susanna, wir haben's.
Wir haben's. Heureka.
Heureka. Hureka.
Hureka.
Ja, exakt.
Exakt.
We got it. Kann gut sein,
falls jemand zuhört. Ich weiß nicht, ob jemand zuhört,
der an einem Hebel sitzt.
Ich kenne so wenig Menschen mit Hebel.
Ich hatte bis jetzt das Gefühl, wir hatten noch nie wirklich eine Hebelwirkung hier im Podcast. Dass wir mal wirklich gesagt haben, wir haben was bewegt. Dass mal jemand zugehört und gesagt hat, ja stimmt, den Hebel können nicht ziehen. Und dann wurde der Hebel gezogen. Und seitdem... Psycho2 bleibt im Wasser? Bleibt in der Pflanze. Die löst sich ja auf. Die Idee ist nur, dass es untergeht. Die zersetzt sich ja. Nee, eben nicht. Die Pflanze zersetzt sich nicht. Das ist ja die Idee. Die Pflanze ist tot, die zerstet sich. Sicher essen die. Ich glaube, Algen retten uns. Ich glaube, Algen retten uns den Arsch. Mögen wir nicht, wir haben die ganze Zeit gemeint zu Algen, wir wollen die loswerden. Algenentferner, Stichwort Algenentferner. Aber eigentlich retten die uns dann irgendwann den Arsch, wenn die ganzen Ozeane voller Algen sind und dann pült dann das ganze CO2 raus und ja, wahrscheinlich so verschiedenstehende. Ist eine ähnliche Idee wie meine, aber halt, ich dachte, ich mag gerade die Vorstellung, dass es untergeht und dann, weil das Meer ist ja super tief, da kannst ja ganz viel reinhauen und so. Es kommt auf den Ort des Meeres. Ja, nicht am Strand, oh, nicht am Strand. Aber nicht. Genau, da bist du. Ich stelle mir vor, so riesige Armadas von Flugzeugen, riesige Flugzeugstaffeln, die ganz viele Samenbomben und dann halt alles voller Seerosen und dann geht das alles unter. Strand ist eh ein Thema gerade. Ich bin ja jetzt mit Schlappen unterwegs, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich bin komplett auf offene Schuhe umgestiegen. Du hast den Trend schon, weiß nicht, 2011 gegen den Wind gerochen. Die Birkenstocks, die du trägst, da wurden wir doch ausgelacht. Ich erinnere mich, bald sind wir wieder in New York. Wir wurden in New York im Comedy-Seller ausgelacht, weil du mit dem deutschen Sommeroutfit da ankommst. Inzwischen ist das, alle tragen Birkenstocks und fucking, ja, laufen mit Cabrio
der Füsse rum im Sommer.
Und jetzt liegen sie mit zu Füssen und
sagen, oh, wir lagen so falsch, Guy, please.
Please, Guy, we were so wrong, Guy.
Ja, aber ich glaube,
ich habe eine ganz komische Lauftechnik.
Ich glaube, meine Schlappentechnik ist schlecht.
Weil ich merke es immer, wenn ich durch Sand gehe
und auf dem Weg hierher gehe ich immer durch
den Kinderspielplatz, direkt durch den Sand durch.
Wie gesagt, da sollst du nicht mehr lang gehen.
Direkt durch den Sand durch. Warum dürfen nur Kinder in Sand? Wer hat die Regel aufgestellt?
Direkt durch den Sand. Und ich habe leider genau so dieses Laufmuster, dass wenn der hintere Fuß nimmt Sand auf und schaufelt sie genau in dem Moment nach vorne, wo der vordere Fuß nach vorne geht.
Es entsteht ein Zwischenraum zwischen Fuß und Schuhsohle und ich schaufel mir quasi selbst von hinten, aber mit einer industriellen Effizienz,
so dass ich nach zwei, drei Schaufeln quasi schon meinen Privatstrand in meinen Schuhen habe.
Und deswegen sage ich auch immer, hab Schuhe im Sand und du hast den Strand immer dabei.
Ist das nicht die Geschichte von Dune? Wie man im Sand läuft? Es ist dieses eine Kapitel in Dune, ja, das habe ich auch nicht verstanden. Oh, immer die Sand in den Schuhen! Sand im Schuh und du hast den Strand immer dabei. Fanta. Mach den Wüstenplanet zu deinem Planeten.
Nee, ich glaube schon, dass es ein bisschen... Fanta sponsert Dune?
Ich glaube schon, oder?
Trinke Fanta, sei Dune.
Ich glaube schon, dass das die Geschichte von Dune ist, wie man richtig durch Wüsten...
Die Menschheit schafft es nicht, durch Wüsten zu laufen.
Ist einfach nicht dafür gedacht, aber es ist...
Ich habe immer noch ein bisschen Sand, aber es ist auch eigentlich ganz cool.
Es hat so ein bisschen Strandgefühl und es hat so eine gewisse Knatschig-Knautschigkeit irgendwie, so Beachvolleyball. Bist du der Anti-Anakin Skywalker, du magst Sand. Ich mag Sand, genau weil es so rau und sahnig ist. Oder was für ein Bullshit-Whatever-Dialogue der geschrieben hat, wissen wir nicht. Ich habe mal wirklich den schlechten Gedanken gehabt, weil man sollte ja, wenn man Fahrrad fährt, Helme tragen. Sollte man tun. Mach ich nicht, weiß nicht. Neulich habe ich mir immer gedacht, da fuhr mir jemand mit dem Helm vor mir und ich dachte mir, was für ein arrogantes Arschloch. Was glaubt er? Mein Kopf ist so wichtig. Was passiert in deinem Leben gerade? Ach so tolles, dass du auf Biegen und Brechen überleben willst?
Ich habe ja so tolle Erinnerungen im Kopf.
Rügen 2008.
Aus wenn es Schande, wenn mir was zugestössen würde.
Ich bin so Rätsel der Menschheit in meinem Kopf.
Mein grösster Schatz ist mein eigenes Gedächtnis.
Alter, Guido, du machst Webdesign.
Du machst Webdesign und du kannst, wenn überhaupt, du hast nur ein bisschen überhielt, weil deine Mutter immer noch hilft in deinem Leben. Brauchst keinen Helm. Ich fahre auch tatsächlich, muss ich sagen, Fahrrad und Helm. Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich wieder ein neues Fahrrad, mein Altes wurde geklaut, anderes Thema. Und ich habe jetzt wieder ein neues Fahrrad, das heißt, ich bin wieder mobil, ich bin wieder aktiv, aber ich trage zwar keinen Helm, dafür trage ich meine Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer. Der geneigte Zuschauer mag sagen, noch mehr Fahrrisiko, noch mehr Verkehrsrisiko, weil ich nichts höre. Ich sage, weniger Verkehrsrisiko, weil meine Ohren geschützt sind. Das heisst, ich habe jetzt wirklich schon mit dem Gedanken gespielt, sollte ich stürzen, würde ich das Ohr voran, was ja eigentlich die Schwachstelle des Körpers ist. Ohr ist ja eigentlich, muss geschützt werden. Man hält sich sofort die Ohren zu, wenn irgendwas passiert. Oh, Hilfe! Und deswegen drehe ich es um, drehe ich die Sicherheit um. Das ist kein Stopp geworden, da kommt das Asthma durch, weil du so viel sprichst, so aufgeregt bist bei deiner Theorie. Ich glaube, das ist ein ganz großer Unfug. Die Ohren sind so fucking geschützt. Nein, die Ohren, man hält die Ohren zu. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Doch, klar. Nein, du hältst dir nicht die Augen zu. Reflexartig. Ich erschrecke dich mal und dann gucken wir mal, was du machst. Du ziehst den Nacken ein, machst den Hals klein, Doppelkinn, schützt den Hals von vorne und du hältst dir die Ohren zu. Hältst du dir die Augen zu, wenn du dich erschreckst? Na komm doch an, wenn da was Schlimmes ist, dann will man nicht, ja. Aber die Ohren zuhalten? Man ist generell zu langsam. Aber wahrscheinlich kommt man gar nicht. Du meinst, wenn der Ohrenwurm dir direkt reinspringt, dann bist du eh zu langsam. Nase zuhalten? Ich glaube, ja.
Die dümmesten Reflexe aller,
ja, das ist ja zum Beispiel das Ding beim Snowboarden.
Beim Snowboarden ist es ja so, also als damals der Lehrer meinte,
alles, was ihr wisst, über Snowboarden
vergessen, dann wurde
Partitionierung neu freigegeben
und jetzt hatte ich mehr Speicherplatz und das Erste,
was ich lernen musste, ist, wenn du stürzt,
Ellenbogen nach vorne, weil das ist ja
kontinuitiv, normalerweise willst du dich mit den Handflächen
Vielen Dank. Die Szenierung wurde neu freigegeben und jetzt hatte ich mehr Speicherplatz. Und das Erste, was ich lernen musste, ist, wenn du stürzt, Ellenbogen nach vorne. Ah, okay. Weil das ist ja kontinuitiv. Normalerweise willst du dich mit den Handflächen abstürzen, aber die Eiskristalle, die stechen dir durch und die zermürben dich, die zermartern dich, meinte er. Und wenn diese Bombe, wenn so eine Bombe fällt, wenn die Bombe fällt, muss ich dann ausatmen oder einatmen? Wenn die Bombe fällt. Eine Bombe fällt, eine schlimme Bombe fällt. Dann musst du ausatmen. Ne, es gibt auch diese Unterdruckbomben oder so ein Shit, habe ich irgendwo gelesen. Ja, genau, die versuchen nicht dann auszutricksen. Du musst erst gucken, ist es eine Unterdruckbombe oder eine Überdruckbombe. Ja, das sehe ich ja nicht. Und deswegen, das ist ganz tricky. Deswegen lieber Nase zu, Druckausgleich, immer Druckausgleich erstmal parat haben, ist in den seltensten Fällen wirklich schlecht. Aber wenn es irgendwann so eine Stadt, so eine Pompeji-artige Stadt gibt und ich bin dann der einzige Trottel, der so gestorben ist. Ich finde nicht, dass das die Überreste von mir sind, weil ich die Unterrückbombe überlisten wollte. Mit zugedrückter Nase, ja. Und alle so, wir rätseln, die Forscher rätseln seit tausenden von Jahren, was dieser junge Mann hinkriegen wollte.
Es gibt verschiedene Theorie, manche denken, es ist irgendein obskures religiöses Ritual, andere denken, er ist ein kompletter Vollidiot.
Wieder andere denken, es handelt sich um todbringende Aliens.
Niemand würde freiwillig so ausschauen.
Warum machen sie eigentlich die Tour, wenn sie alle schon wissen? Der Grund totbringende Aliens. Haben wir gar nicht drüber gesprochen, dass es Aliens gibt, ne? Ja. Und ehrlich gesagt, sehr interessant für mich persönlich auch, weil ich hab mich mit Schrecken in meine Kindheit zurückversetzt gefühlt. Denn es gab diese UFO-Hearings ja. Bisschen merkwürdig, ich weiss gar nicht, was man dazu man dazu sagen soll. Dafür, dass so eine grosse News angeblich rauskommt und unter Eid haben halt verschiedene Militäroffiziere ausgesagt, blablabla, es wurde was gesehen. Ja, aber können wir ganz kurz darüber reden, dass das das schlechteste Interview aller Zeiten war? Der Typ sagt, I have knowledge of bodies and remains and organisms. Und die erste Frage, die ich stelle, wie viele Arme, wie viele Beine, wie viele Augen.
Du fragst dich nach Ohren.
Jetzt hast du mich.
Okay, alles klar, ich gebe auf.
Ende.
Ja, du hast recht.
Stattdessen irgendwas anderes.
Legal Stuff.
Ja.
Warum nicht einfach sagen, wie gross ist der Kopf? Kurz paar Basics. Sehen die so aus, wie man die Aliens, so wie sich Leute Aliens tätowieren lassen, diese typischen grossen Augen und diese komischen Köpfe. Jeder, der diese Information hat, würde einen Teaser geben. Aber er hat nicht gehofft, dass er die gesehen hat, oder? Er hat gesagt, die USA sind im Besitz davon. Ja, aber dann frag doch, selbst wenn er die Informationen bekommen hat, hey Larry, ich habe hier einen, wie sieht es aus, grob, gib mir irgendeinen Fakt, drei Beine, vier Beine, fünf Beine, irgendwas. Jedenfalls wurde über das Flugobjekt gesprochen, ein den Menschen haushoch überlegenes Flugobjekt, eine krasse Technologie, ruckartig kann die Richtung geändert werden, und es sieht aus wie ein grosser Tic-Tac, ein grosser weisser Tic-Tac, was war die Beschreibung? Jetzt erinnere, habe ich mich wie erinnert, an meinen Dänemark-Urlaub 2007, 2008, ich habe meinen Vater am Strand in den Himmel geguckt, und was sehe ich? Ein grosses Tic-Tac, was ruckartig, die, was viel zu hoch fliegt, viel zu gross ist, aber auch noch für die Höhe, für ein Flugzeug, wahnsinnig schnell die Richtung ändern kann und wir haben es damals nicht Tick-Tack genannt, sondern Zeppelin-artige Form oder sowas. Ihr wart nicht so schmissig mit Begriffen. Bei uns waren keine Werber im Raum und so, es sieht aus wie so ein Zeppelin. Zeppelin-artiges Flugobjekt. Zufo. Aber, und das habe ich auch gesehen. Du hast es gesehen, aber niemandem gesagt, oder was? Du hättest vielleicht die gesamte Menschheit retten können. Vielleicht wäre es nicht abgestürzt, wenn du dann schon was gesagt hättest. Hätte man es vielleicht retten können. Ich habe ganz viel darüber recherchiert, habe ganz viel in Foren geguckt, habe auch andere gesehen, in Dänemark, war war ja nicht zu übersehen, alle am Strand haben hingeguckt und gedacht, was ist das denn für ein komisches Flugobjekt.
Wie fucking inkompetent sind die eigentlich, dass die abstürzen, die schaffen es Millionen Lichtjahre durch die Galaxie zu fliegen und dann so, oh, oh, oh, es kommt immer näher, scheiße, scheiße, wo ist die Bremse, wo ist die Bremse, was für Vollidioten. Wir haben die Bremse nicht eingebaut. Wir haben uns so auf unsere Lichtgeschwindigkeitstechnologie fokussiert. Wir haben die Bremse nicht eingebaut. Wir haben uns so auf unsere Überlichtgeschwindigkeitstechnologie fokussiert. Wir haben die Bremse ganz vergessen. Vor allem, also ich meine, so ein Flugobjekt muss ja mit enormer Geschwindigkeit fliegen. Also sagen wir mal so annähernd Lichtgeschwindigkeit blub. So, wenn das mit dieser Geschwindigkeit abstürzt, dann ist wahrscheinlich von dem Ding nichts übrig und von der Erde wahrscheinlich auch nichts übrig. Recht wenig. Das heisst, wenn es überhaupt ein Wrack gibt von einem UFO, muss es mit so, sagen wir mal,
30 kmh abgestürzt sein, mit normaler Fallgeschwindigkeit. Und da, spätestens da call ich absoluten Bullshit. Als ob die irgendwie so observierend in der Luft sind und dann so 30 Meter, 40, Harry, Harry, Harry, zieh hoch, zieh hoch, keine Capriolen, oh shit. Also das finde ich Quatsch. Wenn ich, also ich finde den UFO. Man stellt sich so einen jogartigen Alien vor und sagt so, he he, hier, schau, oder die, die ihm dazugeteilt wurde, beeindrucken will. Genau. Ich kann noch ein bisschen näher ranfliegen, vertrauen mir. Nein, du solltest es hochziehen. Ich kann noch ein bisschen näher ranfliegen, aha. Aber im Protokoll steht das für mindestens bei 10.000 Kilometer hoch. Ja, genau. Das ist doch Bullshit. Oder sie wollten den abstützen lassen. Sie wollten uns Technologie geben. Und warum haben wir die dann nicht? Haben wir sie ja. Ja, aber warum haben... Weil die USA sie geheim hält. Ja, aber warum geben sie sich der USA? Warum geben sie das nicht irgendwo in Brasilien oder so runter? Das hat er auch gesagt. Verschiedene Weltmächte haben die Technologie und es entsteht ein richtiger kalter Krieg für Ellentechnologie. Es klingt alles sehr cool, ich glaube gar nichts davon. Das ist so weird, weil es dann lange sagen, die leute unter Eid aus. Aber unter Eid ist genau wie schwör, dass du sie nicht angegraben hast, meine Freundin, schwör darauf. Das ist auch wie Eid. Man kann auch lügen. Man kann auch unter Eid lügen. Hör auf, das gesamte Rechtssystem bricht zusammen, wenn du das jetzt leagst. Das können wir jetzt nicht sagen. Nee, finde ich aber auch. Mir fehlt bei dieser ganzen Alien-Geschichte der Alien-Faktor einfach. So dieses, ja, sie sind aus der Zukunft gekommen oder irgendwie oder irgendwas, sie hatten drei Arme oder allein dieses Tiktak. Mein Gott, ich denke dir doch eine Form aus, die nicht so lame ist. Wie das letzte Tic-Tac hat zwei Kalorien. Das ist fast nichts. Sagt doch irgendwie ein hyperbolischer Tetraeder oder irgendwie so. Genau, also es war ein kalter Tag. Versuchen Sie sich zu erinnern, ganz ruhig. Oktober 2013 und dann kam da dieses, also erst war dieses Tiktak da und dann kam so ein grosses Tiktak, ein Tiktak-ähnliches. Tiktak, Sie meinen hyperbolischer Tetraeder, sphärisches. Nein, es war wirklich eine richtige Tiktak-Form. Wir nennen es seitdem das Tiktak-Ufo. Okay, also Sie meinen jetzt einfach ein tetraedischer, glypho, multidimensionaler Tetraeder mit schildernden, also es ist Spektrum. Wie dem auch sei, jedenfalls wir wurden dann überrascht, weil von hinten kam ein Skittelsförmiges. Also? Ufo auch noch auf uns zugeflogen. Okay, also Skittels, Sie meinen? Also Skittelsförmig und dann, wir dachten das war es und wir haben das Schlimmste überstanden. Aber von rechts kam einfach mit geballter Geschwindigkeit so eine Knoppersform eines Ufos. Man muss sich das vorstellen wie ein Knoppers. Zwei saftige Waffeln dazwischen. Ich weiss, was ein Knoppers ist. Ja, ist der lecker. Ich kann das so nicht abgeben, das ist doch Bullshit.
Kann es sein, dass sie Hunger haben? Wohan ist Joe gestorben? Woran ist Joe gestorben? Vom Himmel kam so ein grosses, wie so ein Toblerone-Schachtel. Ein Riesen-Mikado. Psch, ins Herz. Aber wie viel, wie, also ich meine, ich stelle bei solchen Sachen immer vor, dass die ganze Welt gleichzeitig zuschaut. Und ich schalte in meinem Kopf immer so in die verschiedenen Wohnzimmer. Und irgendwo sitzt ja der CEO von Tic Tac, der so langsam so daneben so, well, it looked like a giant Tic Tac. Und er so, yes, yes, Yes! Das beste Marketing ever! Die Aliens, die
überlegene Rasse, entscheidet sich für
unsere Tic Tacs und erst mal über Telefon.
Harry, Harry, schau auf, schau auf Kanal
5, ja, Kanal 5.
Und dann so.
Besser, weil er sich so freut.
Wäre dessen bei Sment.
Fuck!
Warum denken die Leute nicht an Sment? Fuck! Fuck! Nee, kann man sich vorstellen. Mentos. Ein Mentos-förmiges... Mentos ist die Ufo-Form. Also, die werden es ja fast lächerlich finden. Die haben ja mitgeworben, ja. Eigentlich haben sie ja, naja, weiß ich nicht. Ufonautisch gut, ne? Weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß es gar nicht. Ich weiß es gar nicht. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es weitergeht mit den Ufos, aber ich glaube, da kommt nichts mehr, das ist einfach Quatsch. Ich bin gespannt, wie es mit den Ufos weitergeht, wie es mit dir weitergeht. Ich meine, gibt es denn einen guten Grund, warum man nicht einfach die Nudes zeigt von den Ufos? Du willst die Nudes. Zieht man denen eine Hose an? Von den Aliens. Ja, von den Aliens. Du willst die Nudes von den Aliens sehen? Naja, also einfach die Körper. Du weißt ja gar nicht, ob die nackt sind oder nicht. Du weißt ja nicht. Warum ist die Nacktheit so ein wichtiges Thema für die Aliens? Nee, nee. Nein, es ist ja Quatsch. Ich meine, du kannst ja jetzt nicht dem irgendwie eine Hose anziehen oder irgendwie ein Oberteil oder irgendwie sowas. Also dir geht es gar nicht so darum, wie viele Arme die haben oder so, sondern eher wie nackt, ob die nackt sind. Nein, ich meine ja nur einfach das. Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wenn ich jetzt so ein Alien finde, könnte ich nicht sagen, oh, das ist jetzt, da muss man jetzt eine Hose oder das ist dieses Krawatten-Giraffen-Problem. Also was zieht man denen jetzt an? Muss man denen was anziehen, ist es respektlos? Ich meine, das ist der einzige Grund, den ich mir vorstellen könnte. Was ich neu gesehen habe, das Toad-Mützen-Problem. Ist der Pilz? Achso. Nee, der Toad. Achso, ja, von Super Mario. Von Super Mario, der Toad. Der Pilzmann. Der Toad. Ja. Ob man dem, wie würde er eine Mütze tragen?
Würde er quasi, wäre die oben drauf ein bisschen, oder würde er die ganzen sein? Nicht komplett oben.
Ist ein Pilz?
Ja, ja, ja. Oder ist der Pilz nicht schon eine Mütze eigentlich?
Ist schon eine Art Mütze.
Wenn er die abnimmt, dann eigentlich so eine Frisur, so eine, einfach so Geheimratze.
Ja, oder so Darth Vader, einfach so Gehirn. Man sieht einfach so blankes, so Gehirnmasse.
Pochendes Gehirn.
So, doch bitte, bitte zieh es. Okay, okay, dann ziehe ich wieder auf. Und mir rät die ganze Zeit nur, okay, ich liebe euch alle, meine besten Freunde. Und darunter ist so ein vibrant Riesenhirn, wo auch so Flüssigkeiten durchgepumpt werden. Brodelndes Riesenhirn
unter fucking Toads Pilzkopf.
Und man denkt, was schmiedet er sich zurecht.
Was geht in diesem Kopf vor?
Wo wir alle dachten, es ist nur
Man dachte, es ist einfach ein Marshmallow im Kopf.
Und stattdessen so ein Reaktor.
Dann denkt man so,
alle Sachen, die ich mit ihm erlebt habe,
ihm ging es immer danach gut. Er hat immer, also klar, auch als wir aufs Abenteuer gegangen sind, als wir den Stern gesucht haben, Luigi, mein Bruder war auch dabei. Ich erinnere mich, ja. Und immer ging es am Ende, klar, er hat uns nicht gelenkt, aber irgendwie, klar, am Ende hat er seinen Film bekommen. Stimmt, er stand immer schon am Ende, als wir da waren. Er hatte die Fahne in der Hand. Das stimmt, er war am Ende schon.
Moment mal. Kann es sein? Wer hat gerade die einzelnen Sterne? Wer? Nein, im Kart, er ist im Kart. Hm. Didi-di-di-di. Didi-di-di-di. Wum, wum, wum, wum. Wum, wum, wum, wum, wum. Das ist ein riesen Hirn.
Aber das ist der einzige Grund, der mir einfällt, warum man Alien-Körper nicht zeigt. Wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem, wem das jetzt? Spannend, die Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar. Da steht nicht die Würde aller Lebewesen, die auf die Erde crashen, ist unantastbar. Also ernsthaft, wahrscheinlich geht es im Kern, hat er keine Persönlichkeitsrechte. Der könnte jetzt nicht die Bild-Zeitung verklagen, wenn die das Alien nackt zeigen. Meinst du? Der, den Alien nackt zeigen. Ich glaube, das ist das Erste, was das Alien macht, sich einen Medienanwalt holen.
Schön, erstmal zu Christian Solmecke, Rechtsanwalt und Partner bei WBS Liegel in Köln.
Erstmal direkt holen und schön erstmal zu Christian Solmecke, Rechtsanwalt und Partner bei WBS Ligel in Köln, erstmal direkt holen und dann so Naja, sie haben gewisse Persönlichkeitsrechte, die in Kraft treten. Jetzt weiss ich nicht, ob Persönlichkeitsrechte auch bei Menschen im... Ich weiss, sie grüten, die Wogen schlagen hoch zu Hause auf Mon Calamari die Würde des Menschen. Menschen? Ja, ich habe mir die Regel nicht ausgesucht. Dann gehen Sie zu Christian Scherz nach Berlin. Ja, aber dann ohne mich. Ja, tschüss. Ja, schönen Tag. Ist das der Film Alien-Persönlichkeitsrechte verletzt und es sucht ein Anwalt? Nein, Taxifahrer. Sie müssen mir sagen, wohin. Ich benutze doch die Uber-Navigations-App. Da steht rechts abbiegen. Ja, ich, wo haben Sie ihn fahren gelernt? Stocksauer. Stocksauer. Puls auf 180. Man denkt ja immer, Alien so wabernd. Über den Dingen schwebend. Unterentwickelte. Aber die so, scheiße hier, scheiße abgestürzt, scheiß Schrottkarre hier, verdammt nochmal, keine Stretzteile, jetzt sind aber noch hier schön meine Hoden in der Bild. Wie wütend, wie wütend ich auch im Straßenstatt, wenn in Köln schon, dann möchte ich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit, der Stress, der Stress, wenn du mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit durchs Weltall rast, ich glaube, und da ist ja, da sind vielleicht nicht so viele Fahrradfahrer im Weg, aber so Tic Tacs. Ja, genau. Wer ist denn nicht da? Wir reden überall, der scheisse Satellit. Wie so fliegen. Wie so fliegen.
Satellit im Mund.
Weltraumschrott im Mund.
Auch ein Cabriolet.
Tücher wie... überall, der scheiß Satellit wie so fliegen, wie so fliegen Satellit im Mund
Weltraumschrott im Mund
auch ein Cabriolet, natürlich haben die Aliens
ein Cabriolet, Weltraumschrott
in den Haaren, Weltraum
Glibber. Ich meine, es kann gut sein,
dass in zwei Wochen die kommen und uns alle vernichten und dann wird man
sehr, sehr kritisch auf diese Podcast-Folge
Wir kommen nicht gut weg.
Wir kommen nicht gut weg, wir sind wahrscheinlich die Ersten, die als
Todesopfer gefordert werden von den Aliens.
Würden wir ausgeliefert werden, meint ihr? Ja, gern. Ja, okay, okay, sorry. Wir haben sie noch nie gesehen, wir wissen nicht, wer das ist. Es ist nicht die bekanntesten Podcaster. Und wir so, wir sind's, hier, hier, hallo,
hi, Florentin und ich,
das ufo.fail,
falls ihr uns schreiben wollt,
wir haben auch ein,
Florentin, Merch, Merch,
und Patience, übrigens von
Thomas, und also
ihr könnt auch auf Reddit vorbeischauen,
reddit.com slash r slash das Podcast
ufo, mittlerweile 10.000 Follower. 10.000 Followerinnen und Follower. Wir wünschen euch alles eigentlich Gute in dieser Alien-Woche. Kommt gut durch, begrüßt sie. Und wenn was ist, meldet euch bei uns. Beamt euch in eine schöne Woche. Beamt euch mal durch eine richtig schöne Woche.
Haut rein, macht's gut.
Und ich würde sagen, wir steigen jetzt selber in unser kleines
Ufo-Gerät und dann gucken wir mal, wie es den anderen geht, oder?
Auf geht's.
Also ein kleines Tick-Tack-Tick-Tack-Tick-Tack-Tick-Tack-Tick-Tack-Tick-Tick-Tack-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick-Tick